[Music]
on this Monday night online sex torsion
and harassment on trial The Hope For
Justice for teenager Amanda Todd this is
Amanda's moment the disturbing
allegations and the plea from the
accused the no-confidence vote in
British Parliament and how PM Boris
Johnson survived defiant and defensive
the Chinese government's new warning to
Canadian military Pilots Eye in the Sky
it's like game changer for the world how
a Ukrainian boy helped repel Russian
forces in a global news exclusive and
out of office most employees right now
are experiencing burnout Ontario's new
right to disconnect law redefines what
off hours really means
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Chris gayles good
evening and thanks for joining us a high
profile sex torsion and harassment cases
playing out in BC Supreme Court a case
linked to 15 year old Amanda Todd who
took her own life 10 years ago after
saying she was blackmailed by an online
predator in an unusual move Dutch
national Iden Cobin was extradited to
Canada to face five criminal charges the
trial is expected to last seven weeks
and nitu Garcia reports on some of the
disturbing details revealed in court on
opening day
Carol Todd has been preparing for this
day for 10 years it's a really
really she has spent the past decade
without her daughter driven to prevent
what happened to Amanda from happening
to anyone else to do this for the other
kids and to provide awareness and
education for parents Amanda Todd was
just 15 when she died by suicide in 2012
after using flash cards to
heartbreakingly describe the torment she
faced her video became an international
cry against cyber bullying now the
long-awaited trial for the man accused
of tormenting her has finally begun Iden
Cobin is a Dutch national extradited to
Canada in 2020 he faces five charges
including extortion luring criminal
harassment of Amanda Todd and possessing
child pornography with the purpose of
Distributing it standing in the
prisoner's box with His Hands Held
behind his back Cobin pleaded not guilty
to all counts in its opening statement
the crown said Amanda was the victim of
a persistent campaign of online
sextortion after Cobin allegedly came
into possession of a photo of her with
her breasts exposed and her hand in her
underwear Cobin is alleged to have used
that as leverage to make her perform
pornographic shows on her webcam and
using more than 20 phony usernames on
four different platforms Facebook Skype
YouTube and Gmail he's alleged to have
sent Links of her videos to her friends
family members teachers and schoolmates
we know how Crown is going to approach
this case they're going to try to show
that the accounts were linked and there
was a single person
we are going to attempt to present
evidence to suggest otherwise cobin's
extradition to face charges in Canada
makes this case unique as well as highly
charged it's internationally this is
starting to happen a lot more
particularly when we're dealing with
cases involving child sex abuse images
Todd has made it her Mission as a mother
to continue sharing Amanda's story and
to advance the conversation about cyber
bullying and to fight for justice for
her daughter much of which rests in the
hands of a 12-person jury
need to Garcia reporting in New
Westminster BC thank you nitu tighter
bail conditions have been imposed on
Jacob hogard a day after the Canadian
rock musician was found guilty of raping
an Ottawa woman in 2016. the Headley
front man will remain under house arrest
in his Vancouver home as he awaits
sentencing for the charge of sexual
assault causing bodily harm in the same
trial the 37 year old was acquitted of
two charges involving a 16 year old fan
but hogard is now facing another count
of sexual assault causing bodily harm
related to a separate incident in 2016.
China is firing back now threatening
Canada over ottawa's response to the
tactics of Chinese fighter jets that's
after prime minister Justin Trudeau said
the planes have been targeting our
pilots in international airspace
Mercedes Stevenson has the latest
accusing Canadian Pilots of provocation
and warning of dire consequences
China is defiant in the face of
criticism from Canadian and Australian
leaders over its increasingly aggressive
and dangerous tactics targeting five
eyes planes in international airspace
China's actions
are irresponsible and provocative in
this case and we will continue to
register strongly that they are putting
people at risk The Intercept resulted in
a dangerous maneuver which did pose a
safety threat to the p8 aircraft and its
crew
in recent weeks China has aggressively
intercepted Canadian and Australian
aircraft out of 60 intercepts of
Canadian aircraft taking part in a U.N
Mission nearly half were considered
dangerous at times the Chinese Jets just
20 feet away and on May 26th a Chinese
jet released metal chaff into an
Australian Air Force Plains flight path
damaging the plane's engines today in
Beijing the Chinese government doubled
down defending its near-misses with
Canadian aircraft saying its actions
were reasonable forceful and
professional and telling Canada to
strictly restrain its front-line forces
and refrain from committing any risky
and provocative acts warning there could
be serious consequences borne by the
Canadian side it's blatant bowling
they're trying to intimidate both
Australia into Canada into changing
their stance National Security sources
say China's escalating tactics could be
part of a push to claim more airspace
making it more difficult for allies to
fly there Chris Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thank you Mercedes in the UK
British prime minister Boris Johnson has
escaped unscathed once again after a
secret ballot vote of confidence
triggered by lawmakers in his own party
he'll Remain the conservative leader but
there is clearly a deep divide in his
caucus Europe bureau chief Crystal
gumancing Reports
the party continues for Boris Johnson
the British prime minister survived a
vote of no confidence the vote in favor
of having confidence in Boris Johnson as
leader was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes that's 32 votes
shy of costing Johnson his job
booed at weekend Jubilee festivities
Johnson known here is the Teflon prime
minister had been feeling the heat for
months I wanted to apologize despite
several attempts at apologies his stick
proof Scandal coding started wearing
thin when it was revealed he attended
several boozy parties at Downing Street
and was fined for breaking his own
lockdown rules the vote was triggered
after at least 54 Tory MPS appealed to
the 1922 committee it's a group of
powerful conservative backbenchers that
have historically influenced the
selection of party leaders the issue
with Johnson and is his credibility and
how his actions affect the reputation of
the party and its chances of re-election
Johnson's predecessor also once survived
no confidence vote Theresa May in fact
won 63 percent of the vote compared to
Johnson's 59 percent still May
ultimately ended up resigning in 2019 no
one foresees Johnson throwing in the
towel but he could be left dangling in a
difficult position and looking over his
shoulder at every critical decision
facing the country what we're going to
do now is take the opportunity to unite
and deliver the question now how will
Johnson unite his party and win over
voters with two big by-elections looming
Crystal gomancing Global News London
Moscow says Russian troops will push
further into the contested Don bass
region after the UK and U.S agreed to
send long-range missiles to Ukraine
Ukrainian forces are still holding out
in key Eastern cities and civilians are
increasingly playing pivotal roles in
some key battles Jeff simple reports
from Kiev with a global news exclusive
about the civilian drone Pilots helping
the Ukrainian military
last summer Andrei pocarasa saved up
enough money to buy a drone
the 15 year old practiced flying every
day at his home near Keith
I'm afraid of heights but I love flying
he says I like taking pictures from up
high but in February pokhara's Town
suddenly found itself on Russia's
Warpath Russian tanks were spotted
heading their way Ukraine's military
didn't know the exact location so they
began looking for a drone pilot drones
have been a tool of War for years but
Ukraine has witnessed a proliferation of
these consumer level drones which can be
owned and operated by almost anyone from
almost anywhere giving the Ukrainian
military potentially thousands of eyes
in the skies it's like game changer for
for the world this drone shop owner says
when Russia invaded Ukraine's military
didn't have any short-range drones so he
put out a call on Facebook for civilian
drone owners to help locate Russian
forces
the response was overwhelming if we
didn't have such operators and drones
who can help Ukrainian Army I think Kyu
already could be occupied by Russian
forces more than a thousand civilians
answered the call to help including the
youngest volunteer pocarasa
the Russians were only a couple of
kilometers away but the military needed
their exact coordinates pogarasa was the
only experienced drone pilot in town
I was very scared but if I didn't help
them the Russians could be here in a day
he says the grade 9 student went with
his father to a nearby field and put his
drone up over the highway before long he
spotted an armored column of Russian
Vehicles his father sent the images and
coordinates to the military and the
Russian column was destroyed pogras's
town was saved is she proud
his mother says it was a sleepless night
yes
I had no way of contacting them I was so
worried she says after that she insisted
they leave to Poland with Russian forces
now pushed out of this region the family
returned home last week
the military rewarded pocarasa with this
more advanced drone and he says proudly
he's also gained more followers on Tick
Tock after posting some of his videos
I was so happy that I helped he says but
also there were people in those Russian
Vehicles they were occupiers but still
people I don't know how to explain how I
feel about it
the weight of the experience is a lot to
carry even for the bravest 15 year old
Jeff Semple global news near key
[Music]
what happens at work stays at work
coming up how Ontario's new right to
disconnect law helps employees Stay Out
Of Reach plus the historic agreement
between BC and a remote First Nation
[Music]
the London Ontario community came
together to Mark a deadly attack on a
Muslim family which shook the city one
year ago today
on this day
we remember what happened
and on this day we must remember
why it happened
and Above All To Whom It Happened
London mayor Ed holder joins the
victim's family and friends at a
ceremony to dedicate a community garden
to the Absol family part of a series of
events being held in their honor police
say four members of the family were
killed after they were deliberately hit
by a truck last June what prosecutors
have described as a hate motivated Act
of terrorism the family's nine-year-old
boy was hurt but he survived a 21 year
old man faces four counts of
first-degree murder in the attack and
the federal government used today's
somber anniversary to announce its
search for a special representative to
combat islamophobia in Canada
they will report they will advise they
will issue recommendations and they will
work tirelessly to promote work to
combat islamophobia the new role was a
key recommendation made by the national
Summit on islamophobia that took place
last summer following the attack on the
Absol family
British Columbia and the taltan nation
have made a first of its kind deal under
the United Nations Declaration on the
rights of indigenous peoples act it's a
consent-based decision-making agreement
which gives first Nations the right to
determine what happens in their
territory and it creates a new model for
sustainable Mining and updated
environmental practices and standards
it's extremely important
that moving forward
Tau tan writes Tau tan decisions tau10
values are at the heart of all of these
projects
the agreement could allow for a massive
gold and silver mining project to go
ahead in Northwestern BC
the right to disconnect ahead The
Province guaranteeing your time off work
stays off work
foreign
have you found it difficult to shut off
from work during the pandemic working
from home might have its advantages but
it can make you feel constantly locked
in unable to escape the new workflow as
Ann gaviolo reports Ontario just adopted
a right to disconnect law to help
employees unplug after hours
the pandemic blurred the lines between
work and home life like never before
especially for those who worked remotely
so the arrival of Ontario's right to
disconnect law was most welcome there's
been such a shifting of what we value
how we want to live how we want to work
but don't be fooled by the wording the
new rules don't actually guarantee
workers a right to unplug from work
Beyond existing provincial laws only
that employers have to be clear about
what disconnecting entails in the
internet age the numbers paint a clear
picture of the problem a 2021 Sun Life
survey found one in three workers across
Canada are suffering from burnout and a
recent poll suggests Millennials more
than older Generations are feeling at
most and women reported higher burnout
rates than men
France was the first country to
implement right to disconnect
legislation in 2016 with other European
countries following suit Ontario's rules
are the first in Canada and apply to
companies with 25 employees or more but
the approach on this side of the
Atlantic leaves more in the hands of
employers we tend to more often than in
the European nations put long hours
working late into the night on a
pedestal the office of the federal labor
Minister tells Global News Ottawa
remains committed to developing a right
to disconnect policy and that coming out
of covid There's an opportunity to make
workplaces permanently better but
there's no timeline and even once
implemented any federal policy would
only apply to the five percent of the
workforce subject to ottawa's employment
laws Ontario was one of the first
provinces to establish a requirement for
workplace harassment and violence
policies and other provinces and
jurisdictions in Canada soon followed
others will likely follow Ontario's lead
the questions remain about how rules can
and will be and forced disconnection for
work is not going to be just a flash in
the pan kind of flavor of the week
discussion because of the Mental Health
crisis that we find ourselves in coming
out of the pandemic and after two long
pandemic years more of us than ever are
looking for support to turn off and
gaviola Global News Toronto
the next Canadian heroes unsung
sacrifice during the biggest operation
of the second World War
the Sky High salute over the national
war memorial today honoring Canadian
soldiers who landed on the beaches of
Normandy at the beginning of the second
world war 78 years ago the flyby was
followed by a reef laying service at the
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier on D-Day in
1944 Canada suffered more than a
thousand casualties including 359
Canadians who were killed Operation
Overlord was the largest military
operation in history and as Dan Spector
reports there's a growing push to
remember those who made grave sacrifices
for the greater good
uh and these are my dad's dog tags on
days like this Harvey Engelberg thinks a
lot about sacrifice and how without a
series of selfless acts in the face of
harrowing danger he would have never
been born how do I repay a debt to
somebody who who gave a family life and
then this picture here his father cobby
Engelberg was a young boxing champion
when he joined the Royal Canadian Air
Force a Fearless fighter at age 24. that
was my dad right there Engelberg was a
radio operator during operation Tonga on
one of dozens of RAF planes to leave
England before midnight the night before
D-Day the mission to draw paratroopers
Behind Enemy Lines in German occupied
France to soften enemy defenses ahead of
the full-scale invasion
not only did they go over enemy
territory before their own troops were
there they had the furthest Mission from
base his plane a Dakota was captained by
26 year old flying officer Harvey Edgar
Jones Jones had given tours of Niagara
Falls and studied business at the
University of Toronto before the war his
niece Helen Peterson remembers him well
the biggest thing I always got a kick
out of was the fact he was so tolly and
a different duck through the doorways as
their aircraft carrying 26 men on board
rumbled over the French Coast into the
dark and dangerous unknown German Flack
suddenly tore through the night sky the
Dakota was hit and immediately in Flames
Pilot Jones ordered everyone to abandon
the aircraft and most did but Jones
refused his parachute according to
multiple accounts he saw cobby Engelberg
injured and unconscious behind him and
decided to attempt a landing I can only
imagine must have looked down and seen
him lying there and make a decision what
do I do do I jump Trump and say goodbye
to my buddy or do what I have to
the Dakota plummeted into the darkness
below crashing on a farm in the small
town of bassenville France Harvey Edgar
Jones died instantly but cobby Engelberg
somehow survived despite severe injuries
including a fractured skull from what I
understand he was under the wing that
was still on fire when they pulled him
out of there a lot of luck involved here
his luck did not stop there the Farm's
owners brought Engelberg into their home
offering medication and treating his
wounds they would take in others only
later sharing details of their
selflessness in a letter to Engelberg
the two heroes in this story the pilot
and the farmers who saved them at least
umel and her son Arthur looked after the
farm and the injured men they cared for
Engelberg and others until an Allied
unit reached them transporting the
wounded to hospital their heroism saved
lives and they would pay dearly for it
to Hamel wrote in a letter that she and
her son were imprisoned by the Nazis for
helping the Allies my son was put to
death by the SS she wrote after six
weeks we succeeded to escape you read
that attack is not fall apart that's
that's crazy the gmls buried Harvey
Edgar Jones on their Farm adorning his
grave with flowers and a cross bearing
the words died for France Long Live
England years later cobby Engelberg
named his son Harvey for the pilot who
saved his life listen I got a name from
somebody who saved my dad so if he saved
my dad he saved me and my children and
my grandchildren so now we're 25
ancestors of cobby Engelberg alone
Engelberg says he'll be forever indebted
to the heroes who made the ultimate
sacrifice
the inspector Global News Montreal
and tomorrow Dan will have part two of
that special story about Harvey's
long-standing effort to honor the
Canadian war hero and what he's doing to
thank the family who saved his father
and that is global national for this
Monday night I'm Chris galus tonight's
your Canada is Campbell River BC a
beautiful shot thanks very much for
watching hope you have a great evening
[Music]
foreign